but first this we're expecting to learn
new information soon about the two
students accused of killing a classmate
and wounding eight others inside a
Colorado charter school 18-year old
Kendra Castillo died in the attack
inside stem school Highlands Ranch now
witnesses say he was shot trying to stop
one of the shooters two of the wounded
students are reported in serious
condition police identified one suspect
as 18 year old Devin Ericson the other
who's legally underage has not been
named this happened about eight miles
from Columbine High School where 12
students and a teacher died in a
shooting 20 years ago last month
David beg know is near stem school
highlands ranch just south of Denver
David good morning John good morning
when the first call came in to 911 was
taking a while to get information about
exactly what was happening that's the
front door of the school behind me and
we're told there's heavy security in
fact we had a crew here last November
who said they had to go through a metal
detector when they went into the school
so how was this gunman able to get in
with a weapon things were actually
happening fast the first shot was fired
the first call to 911 was made a deputy
arrived on scene within two minutes and
students became heroes as they engaged
the gunman who was their own classmate
chaos and fear are what erupted in the
hallways of stem school in Highlands
Ranch Colorado as the gunshots rang out
we heard like really big bangs which I
assume are gunshots
Aurora was sort of spread out across the
room just hiding police say 18 year-old
Devon Ericson and another student
started shooting inside of classrooms
just before 2:00 p.m. local time at
first I thought it was just a drill but
like as I either went on like I heard
yelling like first younger boys and then
I heard police a little bit later some
students tell CBS News three classmates
including Kendrick Castillo tried to
take down the gunman Castillo died
within two minutes police were at the
scene
and we did struggle with the suspects to
take them into custody and they are in
custody right now the local sheriff says
neither Erickson nor the other suspect
who is a minor was known by law
enforcement to be a threat to this
community
police searched Erickson's home
yesterday and they towed a vehicle away
from this garage high school student
Michael Schwartz claims that Erikson did
in the past
talk about causing a lot of harm and
sadness I always thought he was just
messing around and stuff but sometimes
he did hint at it here and then parents
were frantic and they were reunited with
their children at a nearby rec center
after students were eventually evacuated
Fernando Montoya says his son was shot
three times but he was released from the
hospital yesterday he says his son saw
the shooting as it happened the whole
sign of a guy pull up I believe a pistol
I'm not sure like guitar case and start
to shoot while hundreds of kids began
running for safety there were heroes who
emerged from the houses nearby the kids
were running away from the school and
there was several police officers
running toward the school Rock owed to
chalk libs just a few houses from the
school he says he helped a student who
was wounded in the grass near his home
he had a friend with him his friend was
applying pressure to the his back where
he was shot the chalk took the student
inside his home bandaged him and waited
for an ambulance to arrive the true hero
in my opinion is his friend who stayed
with him in an active shooting
environment and and applied pressure to
his wound the entire time he is truly a
hero local sheriff agrees with that he
told us yesterday I fear this may have
been much worse had my deputies not
gotten here sooner and had the students
not gotten involved
listen stem is a school that focuses on
science technology engineering and math
they're about 1,800 kids who go here and
it goes from kindergarten to 12th grade
Gale we haven't heard from the victim's
family or the suspects family but I'll
tell you this police removed a vehicle
from the suspects home yesterday and at
big old letters from the back of the car
to the front
read F society oh boy
David I'm not surprised thank you very
much it reminds me of a Steve Hartman
report that he did for us after the Las
Vegas shooting it's now no longer
shocking when we see these Steve Hartman
is piece that I'll never forget this
pray mourn repeat we keep hearing this
over and over again and nothing changes
and you look at New Zealand with just
Sunday at 38 the Prime Minister to
Senator don't change the laws
immediately and shut it down mm-hmm I
think nothing changes I'm glad the train
the training at least helped with yeah
the first responding and the other kids
knowing what to do and now that the hero
is becoming the story more in the
aftermath of these then the forgotten
shooter who will be lost to history even
though creating this awful awful
situation the tag that David ended on
you know F whatever you know people who
survived are now saying thoughts and
prayers are not enough we need more yeah
we'll see